peu
[Musique]
ton nom frédéric dard dit san antonio
s'est pas de blague c'est sur mes
papiers le 10 à 20 tonio figure sur mes
papiers parce que je recevais tellement
de courrier à ce nom là quand j'allais à
la poste pour les recommandés on voulait
pas me donner envie de me quitter san
antonio et l'administration a bien voulu
mais je peux te faire voir
date de naissance c'est indispensable
je parlerai qu'en présence de mon avocat
que tu ailles je crois que je faisais
avant de devenir chauffeur m 72 voix ça
c'est variable
en ce moment je suis à la hausse bon tu
me prends dans les 86 kg mais je te
promets qu'aux vacances je serai à 80
euros
principales maladies non c'est parce que
tu crois
la principale maladie que j'ai eu écho
que ton calcul aura maladies chroniques
oui comme la phobie du conte quoi je
crois que c'est une maladie tu as fait
ton test pour le sida non je le fais pas
parce que j'ai j'attends la bonne
surprise
tu devrais peu atone et odile oms pif un
peu fort mais tu sais de ce que ça
représente significatif avec jean quand
une dame qui est si je vois son regard
porté sur mon nez je sais qui
j'espère beaucoup d'incidents il te
reste d'origine et combien tout il
manque une que j'ai paumé ce pour mieux
il ya quinze jours quand avait des
cheveux il était gras ou sec
je sais pas en tout cas il était
prédisposé à [ __ ] le camp
les yeux d'un bleu il me semble que ça
soit non je les pense à l'eau de javel
tous les matins la miotte presbytes
astigmate presbytes ça j'ai des copains
qui ils sont mais pas moi tu connais la
longueur de temps sexe enfin je voudrais
pas de faire de confidences ici parce
qu'après ailleurs un attroupement devant
les folies mais je dois faire un aveu il
ya longtemps je n'ai pas mesuré j'aurai
plus de 70 pays signe particulier oui
j'ai le bras gauche et scat et ne les
sens pas vieux combien tu prends une
cuite par semaine à sa suite plus par
semaine avant ça c'était par jour
à mes débuts c'était par jour alors
c'était deux par jour quand j'étais
journaliste à lyon tu vois et puis je
suis devenu raisonnable ça s'est limité
à deux par semaine et maintenant je
crois que ça doit être de parents tabac
chiche cocaïne morphine
non je vais te dire moi j'aime pas me
déformer la vie au point que l'été je
mets pas de lunettes de soleil parce que
je trouve que c'est des gens stupéfiants
tu vois que ça te dit que l'or
l'existence moi j'aime le voir les
choses et les gens tels qu'ils sont
fréquents celle de madère des rapports
sexuels ben ça il faudrait demander
je pense enfin plusieurs fois que tu a
recours à la vente arif et non non non
ça alors c'était dans les débuts mais
c'était pas par avarice 1 parce que je
suis le contraire d'un talent mais le
suis pas je trouvais une espèce de
tristesse puis quand tu penses que tout
le monde est disponible brut compris tu
as eu des expériences homosexuelles non
sur non enfin si tu veux je quand
j'avais il ya 12 13 ans j'ai touché la
queue d'un pote et qui m'ont a fait
autant parfait ça n'a pas dégénéré quoi
tu as d'autres perversions sexuelles non
jeu mais je mersey et d'autres
perversion je crois que ma plus grande
perversion c'est d'écrire parce que
j'écris sans arrêt sans arrêt sans la
région me saoule d'écriture abrutis
d'écriture j'ai besoin car je sais que
j'ai fini d'écrire je sors en mouvement
quelques fois je vais prendre une douche
suchy chronique je suis un monstre
d'écriture alors je crois que ça
équivaut presque à une perversion
on va jouer un cri je vais te faire une
interview dernier coup ok dernier coup
de coeur mon dernier coup de coeur il
remonte déjà à quelques pas mal d'années
prend soin de continuer oui dans les
coups de poing mon dernier coup de poing
c'était à gstaad il y à il ya 20 ans un
type qui m'a traitée de sale français
voeckler il sait très bien les coups de
folie
dernier coup de folie basse et quand je
m'achète un geste n'avait cependant sa
demie de patronne mais une bagnole
lamborghini
pour l'instant c'est une
une mercedes 300 sl trois là que c'est
bien ouais dernier coup de gueule au le
dernier coup de gueule
c'est à pau et moi même je crois c'est
un paquet contre moi que j'ai je veux
aussi faire le plus c'est dur avec moi
même je suis dur avec moi même temps
donc parce que je n'aime pas tellement
et je me fais chier je m'auto fait chier
tu comprends la défaite du rc l'année
coup dur
dernier coup dur ça c'est une histoire
dont j'aime mieux pas parler d'en face a
été logiquement de ma fille on n'en
parle pas non là les coups de soleil pas
le dernier coup de soleil je suis passé
récent j'étais à grasse il ya quelques
temps on était bien là fait bien bronzé
oui mais voilà le bronzage du riche
pourquoi le riche tu crois que les gars
qui travaillent sur you tube et dénis
coup de bol ça gêne et sans arrêt mais
et je veux pas faire chier les autres
heureux vaut-il encore que les autres ne
le soit pas les siens dernier coup de
rein bas j'ai encore le blues ça je peux
pas alors les coups de blues ça fait
partie c'est où tous les jours quand un
moment un moment tous les jours comme il
faut a par sa dépendance ça dépend des
périodes bien des périodes où c'est cool
ça vraiment le blues ah oui et puis
d'autres où ça cette tombe sur la gueule
comme ça mais heureusement je suis bien
entouré je bosse le boulot c'est
merveilleux ton père qui l'avait dit ça
il m'avait dit tu ne trouveras que deux
choses dans la vie que deux choses
valables c'est le travail et l'amour et
tu peux pas trouver autre chose tu as
beau tourner comme tu veux l'amour sous
toutes ses formes maternelle filiales
amour amour bien sûr avant tout et puis
le boulot la joie de travailler la joie
d'en avoir les fruits et de cas qu'on
perd la raison
oui en 1966 tu as voulu quitter donc la
première femme et en même temps tu étais
très attaché à elle mais tu pouvais plus
vivre avec elle fait c'est très
compliqué tu évolues de [ __ ] en l'air
oui j'ai voulu te pendre oui en fait
j'ai pas voulu de l'effet ouais oui je
me suis farci 12 heures comme ça c'est
pas ça s'est passé comment tu sais
cesser ses tricks ont d'abord eu faute
dire j'ai et picoler comme ben ouais bah
oui d'accord
est ce que c'est de la vodka que celle
ci s'est elle compte une expression et
j'ai choisi et j'avais beaucoup bu hui
je suis pas j'avais l'impression que je
ne pourrais pas regarder le jour se
levait que ça tu vois que que c'était
fermé la classe dans des telles qu'une
porte était fermée à tout jamais et que
c'est de la seule issue c'est l'heureux
c'est le revers le ton talent de te
mettre dans des états pareils pascal pas
vraiment de raison ben oui mais je crois
que tout se paie le juste pas cette
facilité ce don d'invention cet amour
des cris je sais pas ça doit y avoir par
moments une soupape qui au prix d'une
certaine folie intérieure c'est au prix
d'une folie bien submersion alors ce qui
était très drôle quand même c'est que
après les gens qui ont écrit en te
disant écoutez quitte à partir si bien
gentil laissez moi un peu de pognon ça
veut dire oui ça ne peut pas savoir les
deux hommes de manu enfin ça c'est un
drame au premier degré mais sans grande
importance pour moi enfin c'était ça
donc puisque rapidement et sur le fait
qu'il soit beau et fine
tu ne peux pas savoir le nombre de
lettres que j'ai reçus je veux dire que
par exemple pour joséphine j'ai reçu
davantage de demandes d'argent si quand
additionnels tout le montant était
supérieur à celui de la rançon versée
c'est étonnant et là quand
j'ai fait le con ben déjà on a essayé de
me positionner
c'était qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
l'accord de casser je crois que je sais
pas je tapais mipi tapait sur contre une
poutre tu sais pertinemment et que je
suis pas ma femme entendue mais j'ai pas
demandé beaucoup de renseignements là
dessus mais c'était tellement couillon
après tout comment ça s il réussit pas
derrière d'un conflit et encore c'était
pas le coup du somnifère
je vais dire c'était pas le petit
machado de midinette ne m'ont pas le
suicide de midinette
comme m'a dit le psychiatre lui a
presque un suicide de valets de ferme
ouais tu vois je trouve l'expression
très belle et qui me correspond fait
tant que tebow un jeu c'est mon côté
bourgoin jallieu c'est mon côté betty
white voix off ils ont accroché une
corde et merde doit alors donc c'était
c'était du vrai quoi tu avais deux
tentatives depuis
non non non jamais et d'autres
tentations non non absolument pas oui
avec le tonton ni d'adaptation s'arrange
quoi oui oui oui c'est bien quand tu
flippes sait très bien que quand tu fuis
tu pleures oui après tu fais l'amour ça
ccpo oui tu fais l'amour oui savons
c'est adorent ça c'est ton et puis après
tu te fais un beau cadeau quand même ça
oui ça m'arrive c'est dans l'ordre plus
réveillé et je vais je vais acheter
quelque chose
la culture est considéré cela vous voilà
avec moi même et je m'offre quelque
chose tu vois alors je vais acheter j'ai
pas table ou un meuble
ou tout simplement une mercedes mercedes
tu as dit je suis un désespéré heureux
tu crois que ça te convient bien cette
définition je crois tout en précisant
encore une fois quelques ça s'atténue
que c'est moins tranchant tiens tiens
puis je le vois les laissons rose la
l'éléphant rose se voiler les phases là
tu reviens tu vois pas non plus si ici
mais tout va bien
ouais ça va ça va mal oui enfin cela il
disait qu'il fera des déficits a eu
cette connerie bâti corti
qu'ils me disaient qu'ils avaient pas
d'éléphants roses regardez là mais ça me
turlupine sourire mais moi j'ai
l'impression écoute s'est pas reproduit
à l'éléphant mais tu
je crois un moment me sens maintenant
puis oui tu stresses n'en veux tu vas y
ça c'est tous mais y aller écouter y
aller les fonds il ya les deux iguanes
qui circulent via les pirates a été
violent mais oui mais bien sûr ça me
travaille parce que quand tu as toi qui
t'es que charmés écoute tu peux pas
laisser faire des conneries pareilles
[Musique]